is the leveling up secretary michael
gove he's with us now good morning hi
good morning joining us on the program
uh is any of this money new well i think
that's a bogus argument because the
chancellor gave us a huge check in the
spending review and now we are spending
it and we're making sure in
wolverhampton in sheffield and in other
areas that we put our money where our
mouth is and that we make sure that
money which in the past was spent too
much in london and the southeast is now
spent in the north and midlands where
it's needed okay although of course
there are quite a few areas in london
i'm thinking tower headlights just down
the road that need quite a lot of money
themselves well there's inequality in
london and you're absolutely right tower
hamlets barking and dagenham
they need support as well and the
government is working with the mayor of
london in order to do that but one of
the the big problems that we have as a
country is the geographical inequality
uh london and the southeast uh an
economic powerhouse but the north and
midlands not so much and that's why we
need to invest in schools in skills
that's why we need to improve wages
that's why we need to make sure that we
level up across the country people
who've been forgotten
forgotten by whom overlooked and
undervalued for years by him well by
politicians the brexit referendum was a
wake-up call
as well as a a clear commandment to
leave the european union it was also a
way of saying to people in sw1 people
like me look
it's vital that you change the economic
model of this country it's all very well
if people are in london and the
southeast and financial services and
others do well we don't begrudge that
but you've got to listen to us and in
2019 the baton was passed to boris there
was a clear instruction deliver for us
we've had two difficult covert years but
now that we're coming out of it we are
making good on that promise by a
commitment to improve jobs and wages by
spending more of the science money that
is so vital to growth in the north and
midlands and also by making sure that
the schools and colleges that people
attend are fit for purpose okay but you
guys have been in power for the majority
of this century
well there have been mistakes made by
parties of both colors and one of the
things in the past is there have been
sincere and uh committed attempts by
politicians left and right to deal with
this but nothing as comprehensive or as
long term as the plan that we're setting
out today yeah okay but you do
acknowledge that you guys have been in
power for 12 years yes i do and one of
the things about that is that some of
you have forgotten these people up and
down the country well as i say there was
a wake-up call in 2016 and one of the
things that is often um you know one
charge that is often made against uh
governments is that they run out of
steam i think what we're seeing here is
a commitment to make sure that far from
running out of steam we're firing up
every engine of the economy i think it's
also important to recognize that when
boris was elected prime minister there
was a new government with a new mission
and that mission was to level up and
we're giving the detail today on how we
do that and very soon after he took
power of course he had to deal with a
global pandemic absolutely and to that
end uh you had to spend uh 12.1 billion
pounds on ppe but 8.7 billion of that
apparently was wasted
not quite
was that panic buying
no not quite firstly i'm not going to
apologize for the fact that we moved
heaven and earth to get all the ppe that
people on the front line needed now some
of those figures are uh uh
accountancy markdowns the relationship
seven billion no yes some of it is
because some of the accountants are
using well the key thing here is that uh
the uh the price that we paid for ppe at
the height of the pandemic is greater
than the cost now and that is because
everyone was in a global race to find
that a lot of it was rubbish and you
couldn't use it no um more than 97
percent of it was absolutely right we
were so excited about those planes that
were coming into raf bryce norton that
we were sending film crews up there the
stuff was coming in from i think i'm
writing saying turkey
turkey saudi arabia china hong kong
globally no the overwhelming majority 97
was used and sorry it was usable was fit
for purpose on the front line i remember
right at the beginning of the pandemic
my friend the shadow uh chancellor
rachel reeves labor mp writing to me
saying please please please get ppe and
she gave us a list of people that we
should contact including people who were
you know uh uh uh theatrical medieval
costumes
and uh that that was on that plane was
not usable at that point everyone was
screaming at us get more ppe and we got
it and that was the right thing to do at
that time and those figures are uh i
think uh uh erroneous and inflated and
more importantly
we made sure we paid for the ppe no well
at the time okay everyone was desperate
to get ppe there were doctors in germany
outside the german parliament
complaining
well it was no case to answer at all uh
no i'm proud of what we did on okay okay
well let's see what happens as far as
that's concerned have a have your tea
while i ask you uh because you'll need
it when i ask you about what's happening
as far as jimmy savile and that comment
that the prime minister uh made uh on
monday i think this is what he said just
to remind our viewers
this this leader of the opposition a
former director of public prosecutions
mr speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile as far as i can make out
mrs speaker
as you can imagine kiyostama not at all
happy about that he was on the show
yesterday actually this is what he said
it is a
peddled by right-wing trolls
uh he's doubled down today the prime
minister it seems in the sun saying that
he doesn't want to apologize do you
think he's got anything to apologize for
no okay lindsey hoyle thinks he has
lindsey hoyle said i'm far from
satisfied about the comments and lawyers
for the several victims have accused
your leader of weaponizing their
suffering you still don't think he's got
anything to apologize for no i think
this is a uniquely sensitive issue and
it does need to be handled with care and
i listen with enormous respect to those
who uh act for uh victims of um
you know the actions of a terrible
terrible uh criminal but um and it's not
a subject that i want to dwell on
because it is uniquely sensitive it is
the case that the uh the cps apologized
for the handling of this case and what
happened in 2009 um and i think we
should acknowledge that an apology was
given at the time and respect that uh he
wasn't directly involved the uh uh
sukiyastama when he was head of the dpp
at the time or he was the dpp at the
time and he says it was it's a slur
well i i i respect kiara's point of view
but i think it is also the case that
it's it's on the record and indeed he
himself acknowledged that errors were
made he to his credit brought in uh a
very distinguished lawyer alison levitt
to look at the situation and then an
apology was made i think we should
respect that so lindsay hoyle um is
wrong as uh are the lawyers for the
sample victory no i'm i'm not saying
that i'm i'm saying that uh uh
in a uniquely sensitive case kyocerma
acknowledged that mistakes had been made
by the organization of which he was head
to his credit uh he was very clear about
those mistakes he brought in an
independent lawyer to look at that and i
think that we should recognize that in
doing that he did the right thing okay
let's move on to parties um should we
i'm sure that story will continue on but
thank you for your
answers for now parties investigations
two more parties were being told about
uh in the newspapers today um apparently
one of them showing that the prime
minister was there's a photograph of him
we haven't seen it yet we're told uh
that it is available or will be of him
at the party at the flat in his own um
in his own flat in above number 11 was
getting mixed up between number 10 and
number 11 because he's number 10 but the
flats above number 11 is it's a little
bit bigger let's remember what he said
on the 8th of december
i can understand how infuriating it must
be to think that the people who have
been setting the rules have not been
following the rules mr speaker because i
was also furious to see that clip
i have been repeatedly assured
since these allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken
he was building our upper heads
well
all of these allegations are being
investigated by the metropolitan police
um there's been
any number of allegations in the
newspapers but again we've just been
talking about the importance of
due process and law and i think it's
only right that we allow the met to get
on with their work and then appropriate
conclusions can be drawn at the end of
it he must have known if he was in his
own flat with lots of people singing
abba hits the winner takes it all well
we'll as i know uh have all sorts of
allegations and speculation in the media
fair enough but the met are doing their
job and until they've concluded i don't
think it would be right for me to
comment
come on he knows whether he was in the
flat or not singing abba hits well i i
all i would say is that i wasn't in uh
no but he was well
there are all sorts of allegations that
have been made i know that some of the
allegations that have been made and i
don't want to get into that but i know
some of the allegations that have been
made um in some parts of the media are
speculation that is not true and so
therefore i can't uh act as an automatic
fighter okay let me put it this way all
of them of course and i'm not asking
each other the met are looking at this
if he was in the flat singing the winner
takes it all with his misses when he
said that he didn't know about any
parties he misled parliament should he
resign
uh i
uh again
you're asking a hypothetical question i
think i think during the pandemic why is
that hypothetical well during pandemic i
think there were some moments when um i
may have been sitting at home and
working listening to music and
concentrating um on
my job while at the same time were you
eating birthday cake um
no but the
the whole point of
was somebody singing happy birthday to
you well the whole point of uh the met
investigation is that uh
you don't have to ask and i don't have
to ask uh uh officers can ask um and
they can make sure that they establish
all the information and once they've
concluded their their investigation
then we can know we are
it would appear a laughingstock he he is
straddling the world stage um trying to
be very statesmanlike and um we've been
looking at some of the quotes this
morning russia and tv reaction if it
were within the power of boris johnson
the report would have been vanished into
the bowels of the victorian sewers of
the city of london and this one from the
washington post the circus uh must uh be
what the circus music forgive me is
winding down for bojo the clown we're a
laughingstock no i think that when
you're uh quoting from uh russian
television the washington post they got
on to the washington post
let's go with that one then if you don't
like the other one are you going to
cherry pick i thought we couldn't cherry
pick oh no
i'll look at both of them okay uh first
of all one of the reasons why russian
television is attacking the prime
minister is the prime minister is
leading the west's efforts okay in order
to ensure
in order it's important to deal with
both of them in in order to ensure that
we defend ukraine's territorial
integrity against putin so of course
he's going to be attacked by russia um
and a single commentator in uh an
admittedly respectable but still
center-left american newspaper oh okay
it's not it's not representative of
world opinion let's try this one but
i'll tell you what is happening
internationally and that is um in the
ukraine there is a recognition that
britain and poland are its two strongest
allies we were told after brexit britain
would be on the margins on the sidelines
of the big international issues but the
prime minister was welcomed by president
zielinski um and vitaliy klitschko in
the in ukraine yesterday okay because
our commitment to provide uh uh
assistance to the ukraine shows that we
are standing tall for democracy far from
being
criticized by uh democrats uh
internationally we are leading the fight
for democracy and eyewear is a badge of
pride the fact that russian television
is attacking our prime minister okay um
what about some alcohol rifkin how do
you feel about him former foreign
secretary old friend of mine he says it
damages the authority of the british
government yesterday he was due to speak
to president putin and was forced to
cancel that very important conversation
because of his domestic difficulties
back home talking about him having to
appear in the house to talk about sugray
as opposed to speaking to putin
i think vladimir putin got the message
when uh the prime minister was in the
ukraine yesterday we've given the
ukraine the weapons it needs to protect
itself we're going to take the sanctions
against russia necessary if there is a
single russian boot that crosses the
border there and so uh i don't think you
necessarily need to uh dial uh vladimir
putin on his mobile phone for him to get
the message that he should back off okay
good to talk to you thank you very much
for joining us thank you